the retail sales figures are devilishly
difficult to predict it's what they they
do tend to get revised quite a lot so so
it's a though the numbers were markedly
worse than the city was anticipating as
I say they are very very hard to uh call
and very very prone to revision the one
the certainty that we did have over
September uh figures was that uh
obviously we had an extra bank holiday
because of the late Queen's funeral and
so uh spending would have taken a hit
anyway but it's really really
interesting when you look at the
components involved in spending food
sales volumes down 3.2 percent on where
they were going into the pandemic so
people are buying less foodstuffs that
reflects uh inflationary pressures I
think you're certainly seeing it in
motor fuel sales which were down by more
than one percent month on month that is
obviously a reflection of higher costs
of petrol and Diesel and then
interestingly you had a big drop off in
non-store sales the bulk of which I
think that includes Street Markets but
predominantly it is accounted for by
online shopping and so there's an
interesting conclusion to be drawn there
that online sales do appear to be under
an element of pressure as well and that
was actually borne out by something that
we heard yesterday from Asos one of the
big online fashion retailers they
produce some pretty disappointing
numbers yesterday so yeah clearly
consumers uh disposable incomes are
under great pressure it's clear that the
bank of England's interest rate Rises
are starting to have an impact and that
is uh of course uh wide retail sales are
falling now on the public sector
finances well these were markedly uh
worse than expected as well as you say
and chiefly it is down to the fact that
government borrowing costs have risen
boring costs alone 7.7 billion pounds
during the month of September the
government has borrowed in the financial
year to date
133 billion pounds that's uh up from the
office of budget responsibilities
forecast which is 127 billion that's
where they thought we would be at this
point in the year and that that is done
largely down to inflation because around
a quarter of the national debt some 28
of it interest payments are linked to
the rate of inflation and accordingly
with inflation uh Rising sharply so too
have uh interest payments on that
component of the national debt so that's
why you're seeing this big increase in
interest payments as I say 7.7 billion
pounds for September up uh 2.2 billion
pounds on the same month last year and
it's actually the biggest uh year on
year it's the first time we've had a
year-on-year increase in government
borrowing since March 2021 that really
does point to the challenge that the new
prime minister and the new Chancellor
Jeremy Hunt face when in terms of uh
publishing this medium-term fiscal plan
which at the moment is due on the 31st
of October there are one or two people
suggesting that might have to slip in
order for the new prime minister to get
their hands on the the books and have a
look at uh Mr Hunt's projections and see
what they want to do but that would
really have come with a risk because is
the the Focus right now in the market in
the markets is on the need for stability
I've been talking to the economist
Gerard Lyons earlier on today here's
what he told me
debt to GDP in the UK is high but it's
manageable but what happens when debt to
GDP is high it makes the fiscal Outlook
very dependent on your assumptions about
growth and also on the outlook for
interest rates I think the scale of
tightening we're now seeing might be
overdoing it but there's no doubt that
we've got to a situation where stability
has taken center stage and that's
unfortunately some people's eyes taking
too much of a center stage but as
someone looking at from the markets
perspective I'm saying well stability
has to now be the issue that's addressed
now I should probably tell you uh
Kimberly what's been going on on the
markets and reaction to all of this
Sterling has fallen again against the US
dollar it's off by uh just over one
percent right now against the US Dollars
soft by slightly less against the Euro
now that is not certainly a reflection
of the data that we've had out today I
think it's still markets taking in what
we heard yesterday from Ben Broadbent
he's the Deputy Governor at the bank of
England and he made a speech yesterday
in which he indicated that were interest
rates to Peak at five and a quarter
percent which is where the market has
been pricing it he said that would clip
uh some five percent from GDP over the
course of the rate tightening cycle and
he went on to say and this is a really
really crucial intervention from Ben
Broadbent he said that uh the market was
perhaps pricing in a higher Peak uh for
bank rate than uh it uh ought to be and
accordingly you've seen Sterling selling
off accordingly people have think that
the peak interest rate rate Rises will
now not be as high as the market has
been pricing and that's a factor there
also where pointing out that the guilt
Market has been showing a few signs of
distress this morning now obviously
guilt yields have come down very very
sharply since uh quasi quateng was
sacked a week ago and most of his mini
budget torn up yields which are implied
government borrowing costs they've been
going in the right direction so far this
week but we've seen a slight blip higher
in yields this morning and that is
something that again the new Chancellor
will be keeping a closed tab on worth
pointing out though that uh the UK
giveaways are now yielding less they're
lower than the U.S treasury counterparts
and that is really quite an interesting
development because they were at very
elevated levels even compared with US
Treasury yields just a couple of weeks
ago
okay Ian thanks a lot